be stronger than any of us but he's not
stronger than all of us the new
Fantastic Four reboot has arrived no not
that one no not that not that one either
yep there we go
directed by the guy who did Chronicle
which I was a really big fan of and
starting a group of really great young
actors miles teller from whiplash
Michael B Jordan from The Wire kate mara
from everything what could go wrong oh
oh okay yeah okay that's that could go
wrong hi I'm Gabe hole writer and what
happened here I really wanted to like
this movie seriously I did but I just
it's gonna take a second to explain just
what went wrong there were warning signs
here so let's talk about how we saw this
coming what sucked how things could have
been done differently and a little
glimmer of hope for the future
flame shields up fire fingers here this
is hashtag news okay just so we're on
the same page a quick recap of who these
heroes are Fantastic Four follows the
adventures of four scientists who are
exposed to cosmic rays and come back
with superpowers there's this mega
genius Reed Richards aka mr. fantastic
comes back with the ability to stretch
his limbs his wife Sue Storm aka visible
woman returns with the ability to create
forcefield that can make her transparent
her brother Johnny Storm can ignite
himself into flames and fly as the Human
Torch and finally the thing Benjamin
Grimm who has super strength and is made
of these really intense orange rocks his
eyebrows kind of look like pizza crusts
delicious together this superhero family
battles Doctor Doom a master metal rival
to Reed who strives to better the world
by conquering it and proving once and
for all that he's smarter than everyone
else it's actually sort of similar to
Donald Trump's plan now how'd they cover
the origin in the movie the movie tries
to follow closely to the 2004 comics of
the ultimate Fantastic Four in the movie
a group of young scientists led by Reed
Richards work to unlock the secret to
enter dimension science II travel at
this is now how they get their powers
instead of cosmic rays now what were the
warning signs that this wasn't gonna go
well the cast didn't even get to watch
the movie until the premiere the critics
that did get to watch it were embargoed
until the premiere meaning they couldn't
tell anyone what they thought until it
was already out the film was made in a
rush because Fox just needed to make a
Fantastic Four film in order to retain
the rights to the franchise now first
remember I want to be positive here is
there anything good about this movie
when I first heard about the reboot I
was really excited to see a new modern
take on the Fantastic Four the first
trailer had a cool interstellar vibe
that was like a dream about a possible
future and cast our characters almost as
explorers going on an adventure more
than superheroes that sounded cool and
new and fresh and
few of the scenes where they first
gained their powers are really cool you
get that on fear of someone seeing other
bodies changing in front of them really
reminiscent to some classic horror
movies like the flaw there was a time
when you couldn't have paid Jeff
Goldblum to wear a shirt okay so that
was the good now all of the rest it
seemed like it could have been a fresh
story but now it's just the movie we've
all seen already it's a superhero team
getting used to new powers deciding to
maybe use them for good yada yada let's
face it the bar for superhero movies has
skyrocketed since the 90s if that origin
stuff is the part that feels the most
tired then we can't spend 80 minutes
building up to the Fantastic Four
teaming up that's basically the entire
movie the x-men don't wait 80 minutes
before getting together excuse me I'm
Erik Lehnsherr tail Xavier
come [ __ ] yourself sir my point are you
faulted you follow me sidenote
another sign that this production was
rushed they couldn't even afford to
finish one of the biggest action
sequence it's the one teased in the
trailer where the thing drops out of the
plane so they just cut that whole
midsection out of the movie so it feels
even more like there's no story until
the end to these movies have to be about
their interactions and in this movie our
heroes barely interact with each other
except when they stare at computer
screens and talking about movies son I
already do that myself and let me tell
you it's really boring Fantastic Four
are at their best when the super heroics
are a backdrop for a story about family
dynamics Johnny and Ben teasing each
other is a must-pass however since they
wanted a grittier realistic take I'm a
story they kind of just left out all the
fun number three the villain yikes
Victor Von Doom is the most memorable
villain from Fantastic Four lore and he
starts as a promising character and I
actually didn't mind the rewriting of
his backstory to make him have more
direct ties to the rest of the
characters but when he comes back as the
big bad dr. doom it's more confusing
than medicine it's not really clear why
he's really doing this scheme we tried
to play it that we were just people a
thing in a situation but even worse than
that you can't even tell what his
frickin powers are force fields becoming
a living rave glow stick look at the
scene here where he just walks through
the hallway and it's inexplicably
unharmed by all the bullets rather than
feeling like a threat he just kind of
floats through the hall that's not a
threat you're not being threatening
you're just moving unharmed like I do
that every day like like look nothing's
happening to me I could be ducking it
for the lack of action let's be real
big-budget summer blockbusters live and
die by the quality of their action for
whatever issues it has Man of Steel did
not skimp on the mega power fisticuffs
and with the Fantastic Four having such
a variety of powers it's easy to
imagine some of the crazy things they
could be doing well keep imagining
because there's only two real action
sequences the inner dimension travel and
the big end of the movie battle that's
it that's it huh now like I mentioned
before a lot of the fun stuff T's in the
trailers we're just edited down or cut
out entirely sorry kids the thing
doesn't find a tank 5 just some weird
choices with the character
interpretations you know there's a
reason why every incarnation before make
sure to have the thing where pants I'm
caught up in what's going on in rock
man's groin area how does a Cappy are
those three rocks it is that the things
thing and I should be paying attention
to your movie do you see the problem
here also they can't really change this
later and give him pants in the next
movie because it'll just be this weird
thing where he was shrieking all
throughout this movie is rubble all
exposed grinding I guess itself out and
sticking with the thing they also made
his classic catchphrase it's clobberin
time into a terrible memory for the guy
it's what his brother used to say to him
when they would beat him as a child
listen not everything needs to be super
dark and gritty let's keep some fun in
this maybe oh and another quick example
of how these weird character
interpretations work people running the
earth the same ones running into the
ground so maybe you desert what it's got
coming to it after dam over here come on
so happening movie like this get made
yes it's fantastic
sailing
it's fantastic yes I got what that's not
a movie that's not a movie as I
mentioned before it seems that Fox's
contract over the Fantastic Four could
extend forever as long as it keeps
making movies or it can give up on the
franchise altogether so box made a movie
by their deadline even though it clearly
didn't want to and didn't give the
movie's attention to deserve also this
part is really speculation but rumor has
it that the director of this movie josh
trank just couldn't figure out how to
make a movie at this scale and his
issues here are supposedly what got him
fired from one of the Star Wars
spin-offs to again Disney and shrank
deny that but this movie clearly had a
lot of top-down problems so it's not
hard to believe that there were
directorial issues okay I know I'm
sounding like a hater but this movie is
just that rough so let's talk about how
they could improve number one give the
villain more think of your favorite
comic book movie villains Loki magneto
the Joker all effective interesting and
highly motivated characters hell the
Joker and Magneto are so interesting
that became main characters in other
movies meanwhile Doctor Doom is barely
in the movie and his only motivation is
always you know huh Doctor Doom is the
flagship villain for the Fantastic Four
show us why to let read and our heroes
enjoy themselves at something we love it
when we get to watch our hero in his
element doing what he loves
whether it's inventing more Iron Man
suits or James Bond trying new gadgets
asides from Johnny nobody in this movie
seems to be having any fun
hell even Superman and Man of Steel got
to wreck that guy's truck for being a
jerk the super tantrums and the
super-powered high jinks this isn't
stuff that we want to lose this is the
part of superhero movies that we love
the whole reason we watched super arrow
movies because we want to fantasize
about what we would do if we had these
superpowers you know I'm saying number
three there are in fact two good
fantastic four movies already made that
you can model the movies off of no not
the one with Chris Evans and Michael not
Hank from Breaking Bad Chiklis first is
Pixar's The Incredibles a heartfelt
action romp about a family dealing with
their superpowers and one of them even
stretches or Josh Trank's own Chronicle
a low-budget sci-fi movie about a group
of teens who gain superpowers that have
got to deal with the consequences when
one of them becomes evil Trank got the
job for Fantastic Four off of this movie
and it makes sense because both The
Incredibles and Chronicle spend a lot of
time showing us what makes these
characters tick look to those films to
see about how to make us care about our
heroes and understand our villains and
their motivations important note this
isn't really a Marvel movie a lot of
people get confused about this it's
important to note that while Fantastic
Four is a Marvel comic book property
it's Foxx who technically owned the
rights
the movie at least for as long as they
keep making movies this exists in the
universe that x-men exists in not the
Avengers now Marvel however would love
to get this property back and here's the
glimmer of hope I was talking about
earlier it wasn't until the amazing
spider-man 2 underperformed that Sony
worked out a deal with Marvel to let
Spidey come home now Spidey's gonna
appear in Captain America Civil War and
it's what fans have wanted forever out
of the ashes of this there's a chance
that Fox could come to their senses and
let Marvel who have been mostly killing
it with their films take the reins on
Fantastic Four now if Marvel took over
here are some predictions that would let
the four live up to their nickname of
the first family Reed Richards and Sue
Storm are sort of like the jay-z and
beyonce in the Marvel Universe the
Oldman power couple can you imagine Tony
Stark ever meeting someone as if not
more intelligent than himself
that's Reed Richards you know have a big
bad and Avengers is Thanos you haven't
seen it yet but Marvel might be able to
show us the version of Reed Richards
that could eat Thanos for breakfast
he's already famous for defeating
Galactus freaking giant purple planet
eating God what's one more then also let
them cross into other properties and a
lot of the force best storylines involve
those crossovers the thing and the Hulk
forever have had this rivalry of who's
stronger I mean can you imagine that
fight scene Johnny Storm and spider-man
were once wisecracking superhero
roommates all the other characters in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe will old
and grizzled wouldn't be cool to get
something smartass Youngblood in there
oh and actually did I mention that
spider-man once joined the Fantastic
Four and it's costume was a paper bag on
his head tell me you don't want to see
that on the big screen okay okay I know
that this was way too much for the
casual fan but I'm just kind of bummed
you know because again I really wanted
to like this movie I'm not normally not
a hater I'm not I hate haters but this
thing had to be said okay because if
enough people say it we maybe just might
get the Fantastic Four movie that we
want in this freaking holding on to the
right stuff we'll go away let me know in
the comments how much you disagree with
me because someone always will but any
other ideas you have for saving this
franchise we're all ears I'm gonna be
swimming around in the comments oh and
hey if you subscribe I promise you we're
not usually this negative I'll prove it
I'll admit that it was weird earlier
when I said the thing didn't wear pants
but I'll stand by my buddy
and I'll join it okay oh what hi did
yours also look like rocks alright what
I was once ashamed but not anymore
condition